the scale and scope of undisclosed
contact with Russian actors by the Trump
campaign has just stepped up several
notches current and former US officials
that are familiar with the exchanges
told Reuters that Michael Flynn as well
as other advisers to Donald Trump's
campaign were in contact with Russian
officials and others with Kremlin ties
in at least 18 calls and emails during
the last seven months of the
presidential campaign these previously
undisclosed contacts are being looked at
now by the FBI and congressional
investigators are also looking at them
in the context of the Trump Russia
scandal six of the previously
undisclosed contacts described to
Reuters were phone calls between Sergei
kis lyac Russia's ambassador to the US
and Trump advisors including Michael
Flynn we have also now learned that
conversations between Flynn and kids
lyac accelerated after November 8th
because they were trying to establish a
back-channel for communication between
Trump and Vladimir Putin this is exactly
what back in April we learned and at the
time it involved Betsy devices brother
Blackwater chairman or CEO whatever Eric
Prince and meetings in the Middle East
to try to establish this back-channel
this doesn't confirm that specifically
but again now Pat what people are
missing is we had a report in April
about the desire to establish a
back-channel with Russia then we have
yet another instance here of
communications that were attempting to
establish a back-channel directly
between Trump and Vladimir Putin once
again we have corroboration not the the
debunking of any of these allegations
and the Trump White House as recently as
January denied that there was any
contact period with Russian officials
during the 2016 campaign we now know
about Michael Flynn we know about these
18 contacts we know about Jared Kushner
and the dozens of meetings that he
failed to disclose and obviously once it
becomes completely undeniable the White
House will say okay okay fine fine that
one thing happened but you don't have
proof of anything else and then we get
proof of the other ones and they say
find that second
but there's no proof of anything else
and drip drip drip we've got a bucket
full of proof it's very suspicious now
how Trump's lawyers have to stop him
from trying to reach out to Michael
Flynn to talk to him you know you'd
think that Trump fired the guy he
doesn't want to do anything with them at
this point letting the opposite is true
and you have to imagine that they're
trying to get his story straight because
I mean if Michael Flynn is requesting
immunity in exchange for testifying
openly yeah you have to think that he
has dirt on Trump and he might be able
to turn on him or might be swayed to
yeah no doubt about it the white house
so what are different people saying when
asked for comment about this the White
House didn't respond to requests for
comment
Michael Flynn's lawyer declined a
request for comment in Moscow a Foreign
Ministry official declined to comment a
spokesman for the Russian embassy in DC
said we do not comment on daily contact
with local interlocutors once again this
also continues to corroborate past
reports so it is all coming off the
walls Reuters is reporting the same
thing that we were hearing in April
about a desire to create a back-channel
may be starting a feud with the
intelligence community while you're
colluding with Russia isn't the best
idea if you are soon to be President of
the United States send me your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show